c'est un scénario que le président
israélien commence à connaître
réouven rivlin est à nouveau chargé de
trouver une issue à l'impasse politique
alors que benyamin nétanyahou n'est pas
parvenu à former une coalition
le chef de l'état a chargé son opposant
yaïr lapid de former le nouveau
gouvernement israélien sur la base des
recommandations que j'ai reçu des partis
de la knesset et conformément à
l'autorité qui m'est accordée en vertu
du paragraphe 9 de la loi fondamentale
sur le gouvernement
je viens de m'entretenir avec le député
de la knesset hier la pid et de
l'informer que je lui donne le mandat de
former un gouvernement
mais la tâche de yaïr lapid s'annonce
également compliquée même si le
centriste souhaite former un
gouvernement d'union nationale
il n'a pour l'instant rassemblé que 51
députés autour de lui encore loin donc
des 61 élus nécessaires pour obtenir la
majorité pour tenter de réussir là où
benyamin netanyahu a échoué dire lapide
devra négocier à la fois avec la
formation de droite radicale dirigé par
naftali bennett et les partis disent
arabe
nous avons besoin d'un gouvernement qui
reflétera le fait que nous ne nous et y
sont pas les uns les autres
un gouvernement dans lequel la gauche la
droite et le centre travailleront
ensemble pour faire face aux défis
économiques et sécuritaires
en attendant benyamin nétanyahou ne
renonce pas à se maintenir au pouvoir
alors qu'il est jugé pour corruption et
malversations
le chef du likoud a ainsi accusé son
opposant de vouloir former en dangereux
gouvernement de gauche
il s'est également dit certain de
pouvoir former une coalition majoritaire
lorsque nous formerons un bloc de droite
ferme de 59 sièges
nous aurons un gouvernement qu avec un
tel bloc et lorsque le choix est un
gouvernement de droite ou des élections
il y à quelques membres de la knesset
qui se joindront à nous malgré leurs
dénégations et ensemble nous formerons
un gouvernement de droite et ne rompt
pas aller jusqu'aux élections
le prix route malgré ses déclarations
optimistes les sondages ne semblent pas
être en faveur de benyamin nétanyahou
selon la chaîne israélienne 13 43% des
israëliens soit war yaïr lapid et
naftali bennet former une coalition
la population devra donc attendre
l'évolution de ces nouvelles tractations
politiques en cas d'échec ce sera le
retour aux urnes pour la cinquième fois
en moins de trois ans